on va plus loin avec Annie va
journaliste indépendante bonjour Anne
bonsoir je rappelle que vous publiez à
l'occasion de cette campagne pour
l'élection présidentielle ici en France
un livre enquête la France de face aux
éditions fayardes et témoignages de
Français qui comme en 2017 avec dans
quelle France on vit vous livre leurs
attentes et leurs illusions absolument
vous avez tout dit il faut le dire
face à vous Jim cendré de la rédaction
de France 24 bonjour James bonsoir le
compte à rebours semble bel et bien
enclenché au Mali cette fois le divorce
est consommé entre Paris et Bamako la
gente malienne renvoie l'ambassadeur de
France il a trois jours pour quitter le
pays la semaine dernière c'était
Jean-Yves Le Drian qui qualifiait dit
légitime et d'irresponsable pouvoir
maliens pour avoir exigé le départ du
contingent danois de la task force
européenne takuba écouté
maintenant la jinte depuis hier remet en
cause sur des allégations infondées le
déploiement des forces danoises un
nouveau signe de fuite en avant je
voudrais dire ici avec beaucoup de force
que cette jintète illégitime et qu'elle
prend des mesures irresponsables
mépris ce sont des propos que je
condamne qui sont inacceptables et je
crois que les insultes ne sont pas une
preuve de grandeur nous sommes disposés
à discuter avec la France ou d'autres
sur des questions de substances
il s'agit pas de questions
irresponsables ce que nous essayons de
faire c'est de défendre les intérêts de
notre pays voilà et puis également
Florence par les ministres des armées
appelé à se taire par les officiels
maliens ça commence à faire beaucoup
dans ces conditions Anne la France
peut-elle encore rester au Mali
là on a du mal à penser que ça soit
possible parce qu'on a on entend quand
même rarement ce genre d'échanges en on
c'est-à-dire officiellement c'est c'est
très fort c'est très rare mais il faut
essayer de se pourquoi nous sommes au
Mali nous la France nous sommes au Mali
parce que nous avons décidé de combattre
le terrorisme mais finalement à quel
prix là je crois que les autorités
françaises sont en train de se le
demander Florence Parly on a parlé
elle-même doit-on rester à tout prix le
prix là il commence à être assez élevé
parce que c'est c'est l'air du soupçon
les Danois on va en parler sont obligés
de partir mais quand les Maliens disent
officiellement et ce qu'ils ne viennent
pas pour préparer quelque chose contre
notre pays on peut se dire que les ce
qui était censé être le but et compris
par les deux parties aujourd'hui n'est
plus compris le soupçon du
néocolonialisme en fait c'est invité
dans cette intervention française au
Mali il est temps de partir James André
écouter difficile à dire parce que il
faut se souvenir que d'abord c'est
l'opération barkhane c'est quelque chose
de très gros et de très complexe et qui
dépassent les frontières du Mali le
problème du Mali c'est la base notamment
de Gao qui est une énorme base
logistique et le hub qui est une ville
c'est monstrueux hein
8 jours alors on était j'étais sur place
au mêlée des heures avec une équipe il y
a eu le mort d'un soldat d'ailleurs
juste pour revenir sur le dossier mal
des rapports franco-maniens c'est la
première fois que le gouvernement malien
n'a pas émis de communiquer n'a pas
réagi à la mort d'un soldat français sur
ce théâtre il faut souvenir que c'est le
53e à tomber depuis 2013 dans les
opérations Serval puis barkham mais
évidemment le d'abord c'est quand même
difficile de partir on s'en souvient
aussi à la force à couper on va en
parler tout à l'heure il y a des
opérations c'est évident mais c'est vrai
qu'on arrive à un stade où évidemment la
question va se poser c'est à dire
on est plus voulu ça coûte 1 milliard
d'euros ça coûte la vie à 53 soldats
français et surtout comment atteindre
les objectifs qui ont été définis pour
cette force française il faut veut dire
que lors du sommet de peau en 2020 il y
a quatre objectifs qui avaient été
définis un volet militaire un volet
politique de stabilisation du pays un
volet de nation building de retour de
l'État malien au nord et puis un volet
de développement et bien c'est 3
derniers volets dont je viens de parler
ils sont impossibles dans les conditions
actuelles donc à un moment donné la
France pourrait se dire bah écoutez on
va pas y arriver juste avec l'armée donc
il va falloir sortir la question est de
savoir comment le faire sans avoir l'air
d'abandonner le Mali c'est compliqué
s'en aller c'est faire le jeu de la
Russie aujourd'hui à nievin
des facto oui même si c'est pas le but
mais il y a déjà depuis des mois on en
parle beaucoup une présence militaire
qui a l'air d'être Russe sans le dire
qui se trouve sur place et dans d'autres
pays en Afrique donc
et bien sûr la Russie a toujours profité
de de du fait que d'autres partent donc
ça fait partie de la diplomatie russe
aujourd'hui du soft power qui devient un
Power militaire sans le dé finalement
avec les forces Wagner bien sûr donc la
propagande russe ça fait partie
maintenant de la propagande russe
projette cette puissance cette image de
puissance qui est celle justement d'être
là sans vraiment que cela soit reconnu
et aujourd'hui on arrive au piège qui
est celui qu'on est en train d'écrire ce
soir parce que pour dire qu'il faut que
l'ambassadeur s'en aille c'est
véritablement un piège les
paramilitaires comme le groupe Wagner et
les conseillers techniques russes parce
qu'ils sont aussi présents peuvent-ils
réussir là où la France a semble-t-il
échoué face à ces groupes djihadistes
alors écoutez c'est très difficile à
dire mais en tout cas c'est ce que
pensent les manières c'est à dire que
pendant une semaine sur place j'ai pu
parler à beaucoup de personnes maliennes
et notamment des gens qui sont à dire
dans l'appareil
sécuritaire qui vous disent mais oui
mais bien sûr ils ne s'embarrasse pas de
droits de l'homme pour eux c'est très
simple ils vont arriver ils vont faire
le ménage en six mois vous allez voir ce
que vous allez voir or je pense que
c'est un calcul qui est faux c'est à
dire que vous avez quand même plusieurs
composantes évidemment dans ce alors
certes par exemple on a vu l'opération
barkhane a été extrêmement performante
face à l'EGS l'État islamique
au Grand Sahara où l'organisation a été
décapitée on l'a vu il y a eu une
opération militaire incroyable qui a
duré 5 mois ils ont pris tous les points
d'eau ils ont absolument asséché le IGS
mais faut se souvenir que ça c'est
quelque chose qui vient plutôt de
l'extérieur quand on vient plutôt sur le
gsim le GSM donc le soutien le
groupement de soutien à l'islam est
musulman de Yaga Ghali là vous êtes sur
quelque chose qui est
endogène qui est là qui est très
difficile à traquer dans lequel la
population est immiscée on peut pas
arriver et tout simplement des
fourraillés se débarrasser du problème
ça n'est pas vrai et c'est là que le
problème va se poser après sur les
Russes comme pour les Russes comme ça
c'est posé pour les Français comme c'est
un problème de long terme c'est un
problème politique auquel il faut
apporter aussi d'autres types de
solutions et je dirais juste une
dernière chose vous souvenir aussi que
les Français n'ont pas forcément
totalement disparaître il pourrait tout
à fait s'ils partent aussi se replier
vers le Niger utiliser les drones les
avions les forces social et tout cela
peut avoir une efficacité mais en tout
cas lui les Russes va être très
difficile pour eux et il y a des gens
sur place on a dit qu'ils m'ont dit vous
savez les djihadistes ont extrêmement
contents de voir les Français
potentiellement s'en aller s'ils le font
parce que ça va être beaucoup plus
difficile pour les Russes que pour les
Français qui sont habitués à ce terrain
depuis 10 ans d'ici là en tout cas sont
déjà les Danois qui eux se sont en a
laissé une demande de Moscou en tout cas
ça serre les intérêts de la Russie Annie
va se départ des Danois ils étaient dans
le collimateur de Moscou on peut
imaginer que c'est une demande du
Kremlin je sais pas véritablement si ça
sert les Russes je pense que c'est
l'Ukraine a évidemment direct
indirectement bien sûr j'allais parler
de l'Ukraine puisque en Ukraine les les
les évidemment les Danois
posaient un problème aux Russes et il le
pose tout le temps donc mais je crois
que le problème du contingent d'un noir
et plus compliqué que ça c'est c'est le
problème de la de l'amalgame finalement
entre aide humanitaire et aide militaire
puisque les Maliens le disent la jointe
l'a dit que le a souligné à remercier
les Danois pour le raid humanitaire leur
aide au développement qui est énorme en
termes financiers et en fait quand on va
sur place moi je l'ai beaucoup vu en
Afghanistan et tout le monde joue
là-dessus aujourd'hui il y a un amalgame
aujourd'hui entre l'humanitaire et le
militaire et là la jeune joue sur les
deux tableaux finalement
je me sens Brice 5000 la force takuba le
départ de ces danois d'autres Européens
vont du coup faire défections alors oui
ça la mine bien sûr et ça la mine parce
que d'abord c'était une force qui a été
difficile à mettre sur pied c'est une
force qui a été voulue par la France qui
est commandée d'ailleurs par la France
et qui était voulu par par l'Élysée
puisque c'était on va dire la première
véritable laboratoire du neuroforce
d'une Europe de la défense sur un
théâtre extérieur qui se travaillerait
ensemble etc donc ça évidemment c'est
mauvais par ailleurs il faut savoir
qu'il y a trois autres pays qui sont sur
la sellette entre guillemets il y a le
Portugal la Hongrie et la Pologne qui
attendent on va dire un accord bilatéral
avec le Mali donc c'est très compliqué
cette obligation les plans de la France
mais je pense aussi qu'il faut pas se
souvenir que dans ce dossier malin il y
a une autre chose c'est qu'il y a quand
même une fuite en avant de la jante qui
se trouve dans une situation où et bien
elle est sous sanction elle sait qu'elle
va elle va tomber en panne de cash très
bientôt d'ici quelques mois si la
situation ne change pas parce que
aujourd'hui elle ne peut pas se financer
sur le marché ouest africain elle sait
aussi que colonel pucciste ce n'est pas
un métier qui toute l'expérience récente
le coup ils ont tendance définir s'il
lâche le pouvoir en prison donc est-ce
qu'ils sont pas aussi dans une logique
je pense qu'il y a pas forcément
de résister de jouer ce match de la
panne du panafricanisme et de la du
nationalisme de l'autre côté c'est aussi
une une fierté du président Macron
justement de montrer que cette Europe de
la défense existe et là on est
finalement un peu faiblement dans beau
draps pour savoir si elle existe
véritablement alors que c'est une
priorité du quinquennat d'où la
nécessité d'afficher une solidarité avec
les Danois oui mais il faudrait plus que
l'afficher
les États-Unis viennent d'appeler leurs
alliés à rapatrier d'urgence leur
ressortissant djihadiste détenu dans le
nord-est de la Syrie une déclaration qui
intervient après une semaine de siège de
la prison d'assaké ou le groupe état
islamique a réussi à provoquer une
mutinerie Annie français dans cette
prison mais est-ce le signal du destin
peut-être qu'il faut maintenant songer
sérieusement rapatrier ces Français qui
ont combattu dans les rangs du groupe
état islamique mais je crois qu'on
n'avait pas besoin de ça pour se rendre
compte que il faut rapatrier en tout cas
c'est une question qui divise beaucoup
de monde et l'État français n'aura pas
pris pas ça c'est quand même la grande
information il faut pas croire qu'on
rapatrie c'est une question qui a été
tranchée pour le moment et on en débat
plus du tout il faudrait peut-être que
ça va aider à la faire revenir dans le
débat mais on n'aura pas pris pas et
pour preuve il y a eu en
à l'automne dernier en septembre 21 la
France a défendu ce refus devant la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme de
rapatrier mais ça c'était avec des
femmes de djihadistes et des enfants de
djihadistes mais c'est très important
parce on a dans un autre camp des
dizaines de milliers de femmes et
d'enfants et les enfants sont victimes
de la guerre et l'État français dit
qu'il faut il faut les rapatrier mais
séparer des mamans finalement donc au
cas par cas donc il est grand temps de
se poser la question et personne se la
pose et pendant que personne se la pose
et bien les djihadistes font ce qu'ils
veulent c'est le chaos c'est le chaos
dans le nord-est de la Syrie ça l'a été
depuis longtemps et ça le reste ça c'est
quand même la grande information c'est
que ça le reste les djihadistes sont
encore capables de mener ce genre de
libération de provoquer des mutineries
etc même si on n'a pas complètement
d'informations sur le terrain il y a des
chiffres qui sont pas tout à fait les
mêmes mais ça montre quand même une
instabilité énorme sur le terrain cet
assaut il était prévisible James il
témoigne en tout cas du retour de daesh
au premier plan
alors daesh à communiquer en disant
qu'il s'agissait simplement d'une
opération de libération de prison ce que
je pense pour être honnête c'est que je
pense que c'est oui bien sûr daesh n'a
jamais disparu en réalité a toujours été
là caché en arrière-plan il y a eu il y
a eu des époques où
dans la vallée tout à fait du côté en
fait de bagouse du désert qui est au
nord enfin voilà c'est là qu'on les loge
aujourd'hui le fait que ils ont continué
à attaquer il y a eu des périodes ou à
RACA après la fin de du Khalifa après la
chute de babouz on était dans une
situation où il y avait un attentat par
jour ça s'est calmé ces derniers mois la
situation sécuritaire est moins mauvaise
qu'elle n'a pu l'être malgré tout si
effectivement pour l'instant l'état
islamique n'est pas en mesure de
reprendre du territoire oui ils sont
présents il faut se souvenir que toutes
les revendications parce que je pense
qu'il y a deux états islamiques en
réalité c'est-à-dire vous avez les
combattants internationaux le jihad
international mais vous avez aussi les
combattants locaux et beaucoup des
prisonniers de cette prison était des
Irakiens des Syriens et ça on est sur
une revendication locale qui est une
revendication d'Arabes sunnite et
cette revendications finalement aux
sortir de ce qui a pu se passer pendant
toute cette guerre contre l'organisation
état islamique et la guerre en Syrie
elle est intacte c'est-à-dire que ces
gens-là sont toujours quelque part mises
aux banc ils sont dans une situation
aujourd'hui ou leur ville ont été
détruites il faut se souvenir qu'il y a
une véritable animosité à la fois
culturelle et réelle sur le terrain
entre les Kurdes et les arabes sunnites
de cette zone qui se détestent
cordialement il y a des problèmes
notamment à cause de la conscription à
des problèmes liés à la manière ils sont
vus comme des comme des envahisseurs en
réalité comme des
occupants dans anony comme raquette Tab
4 en bagouse etc pour c'est pas la
population naturelle de ces autres donc
évidemment il y a une tension c'est
compliqué et évidemment le hiper peut
rejaillir
noir on est dans un endroit
géopolitiquement ou c'est le trou noir
puisque ce sont des autorités Kurdes qui
sont finalement non reconnus
internationalement il y a pas d'état
kurde et de l'autre côté on a un régime
syrien avec lequel la France a rompu les
relations diplomatiques depuis 2012 donc
il peut s'y passer absolument tout ce
qu'on veut c'est une espèce de
Guantanamo vice géant et c'est ça que
j'aimerais que nos spectatrices étaient
spectateurs comprennent c'est à dire que
il y a pas de loi qui est respectée dans
ces endroits-là donc du coup on se Grace
j'allais dire à cette attaque on se rend
compte que rien n'est réglé sur place
mais non rien n'est réglé sur place
c'est pour le moment de nos autorités
n'ont pas la solution du tout et ça
c'est ça ça c'est dramatique
Anne pour ce mot de la fac qui à défaut
en tout cas d'être enthousiasmant nous
place face à la gravité des enjeux du
monde merci d'avoir été avec nous merci
également à James André c'était on va
plus loin place à présent au focus le
boom démographique est terminé en Inde
pour la première fois l'indice de faux
fécondité est tombé sous le seuil de
remplacement de renouvellement de la
population